natsu merci d'être avec nous et merci
d'avoir créé cette association give back
charity
il soutient des projets humanitaires au
congo notamment elle aide les femmes qui
ont été victimes de violences sexuelles
au congo et qui sourit d'helaba par le
docteur denis mukwege gay qui et prix
nobel de la paix en 2018 et c'est vrai
qu'il fait partie de l'association avec
nasser give à la merci d'être là alors
tous les termes en soient là parce que
c'est vrai que c'est une association
très importante pour toi et tu fais un
travail énorme à la thur exactement et
elle fait partie de l'association ses
sacs à dos et avec elle aussi que je
fais ça c'est c'est quelque chose qui me
tient vraiment à coeur
encore plus pour l vis-à-vis de ma mère
mais vraiment parce que il se passe il
se passe vraiment des choses horribles
au congo en particulier au kivu qui à
l'est de à l'est de la république
démocratique du congo est ce que fait le
docteur dennis moukouéké c'est c'est
incroyable c'est vraiment lui c'est
vraiment lui le super héros en vérité ça
juste en 2018 il a fait scission de 55
mille opérations ici surnommé l'homme
qui répare les femmes et ça que s'engage
contre les mutilations génitales
pratiqués sur les femmes en république
démocratique du congo c'est un voilà
c'est un gynécologue et militant bien
sûr des droits humains au congo alors on
va voir une petite vidéo voilà give back
charity regarde avec les tories si ça
tient qu'à moi j'aime rêver le monde
entier
là tout de suite pour commencer pour
faire le premier pas je me suis tourné
vers le congo qui délie sont connus qui
a changé la vie de plein de fin qui a
gagné le prix nobel de la paix parce
qu'il a réparé
à un nombre incalculable de femmes
la charge est en retrait sur c'est sympa
[Musique]
gratuitement
c'est parce qu'il fallait le faire et
femmes qui viennent ici la plupart ils
ont vécu des drames la plupart ont été
de viol et il yal'association événement
qui est là pour eux pour aider ces
femmes là
[Musique]
t'as vu
valises à remercier
dalida merci données venir nous en
parler aussi serré que c'est important
pour nous et c'est important que dazhou
s'impliquent voilà dans cette
association
oui c'est très important parce que le
professeur c'est qu'il fait là bas c'est
c'est vraiment incroyable toutes ses
formes là il n'y a pas que les femmes
aussi à lui les petites filles même idée
des enfants sur et il faut lui donner en
quelque sorte un coup de main en fait
parce que c'est lui les super héros et
nous on est là juste pour apporter un
petit quelque chose à une mise en
lumière des liens sur l'airé et dans les
réseaux sociaux je le vois tout le temps